Let me just explain it to explain to the viewers here why this isn't just some
like psychological geek conversation.
This is actually really relevant to a lot of the things that we'll be talking
about and that your audience probably cares about because one of the most
contested ideas and the social sciences is the idea of innateness and the ideas.
Well,
if something has a need,
then it can't.
It can't vary across societies and if it varies across the side is then it's not
a neat.
And if gender barriers,
if masculinity or femininity vary across societies,
there is not an eight.
It's socially constructed,
but that's the wrong understanding of the neatness.
The definition that I use comes from Gary Marcus was actually a neuroscientist
here at Nyu.
He says innate doesn't mean hardwired.
There's almost nothing.
Interestingly,
it's hardwired in eight means structured in advance of experience,
but that experience can still revise it.
And boy does that work for gender,
for almost everything.
Almost everything that we're not a blank slate about anything.
And something used to tell my students at Uva,
I taught at Uva for 16 years is,
you know,
everything's a social construction,
masculinity,
femininity,
cancer,
the sun,
death,
everything.
There's a social construction for you won't find a society that doesn't have
thoughts about these things.
But the fact that societies have social constructions tells us nothing about
whether there is not also an underlying biological reality.
And in almost all cases there is,
you wouldn't be able to communicate,
which is one of Eo Wilson's comments,
right?
When,
I mean Wilson is the entomologist to study down.
So it's Harvard and also wrote number of books about sociobiology that got him
in trouble with the radical leftists.
And he said,
even if we could communicate with ants,
there'd be nothing to say to each other because they're fundamental mode of
being in the world is based on motivations and interests that are so different
from ours that there wouldn't be any structure for communication.
And you can kind of tell that with regards to the animals that we make friends
with,
right?
We're much more likely to make friends with animals who has a,
who have a fundamental biological and social nature that's very close to ours,
like dogs,
because we can basically speak their language,
even though not completely a mammo language of love.
And you know,
I miss you and I want to play with you.
Yeah,
that's right.
exactly.
And that bonding.